hey it's Riley from Jedi councils rule
of two and I know I know you're clicking
you're wondering you're worrying you're
upset Luke Skywalker is no longer among
the living and the Star Wars universe
and is instead one with the force as
seen at the end of the last Jedi Luke's
force projections saved the resistance
giving the galaxy the spark of hope it
needed the legend of Luke Skywalker
United a galaxy but divided the fans but
it's not all bad Mark Hamill's Luke
Skywalker will be back in episode 9 as
announced by Lucasfilm this gave fans a
nice break from the JJ Abrams mystery
box instead of teasing or hinting at an
inevitable surprise where Luke's force
goes up in the movie much as they did
with Yoda in the last Jedi we instead
get the cold hard facts Luke will be
back but is that enough assuming it's
just in a force ghost capacity that
still might not be enough to cushion the
blow many fans had after seeing the last
Jedi so what if I told you there was a
way to a make Luke a living bean again
and show him kickin ass as a Jedi Master
be echo the prequels pleasing those fans
and see ease the pain of those who
heeded the treatment of Luke's character
in the last Jedi it's simple really
it's been done before and it can fit
nicely into the ongoing story in themes
set up in the force awakens and the last
Jedi flashbacks or as we'll call him
here force packs let me explain JJ
Abrams started the trend by adding
something into Star Wars movies never
seen before flashbacks when Rey meets
Maz Kanata on the planet of toka Donna
she's inevitably drawn to we calling the
force it leads her underground to a lone
wooden chest where she finds the old
lightsaber of Anakin Skywalker that was
well as you know later given to his son
Luke by obi-wan Kenobi and as you know
the lightsaber was cut from the hand by
Vader on vestments so many years later
the lightsaber seemed to call to Rey and
she answered but when she grabbed it by
the hilt boom we witness our very first
flashback in the Star Wars universe ever
and not just one flashback we see Bespin
the hallway where Luke fought fader
we then see Luke cloaked and hidden from
our sights leaning on r2d2 then another
flash we see the Knights of Ren led by
kylo Ren kill a number of unknown people
and
even see a young ray left behind on the
planet jakku the flashbacks end with obi
wan's voice telling ray those are
flashbacks plain and simple so let's
move on to the last Jedi where the
flashbacks were used to fill in some
gaps from the past and how Ben's Solo
fell to the dark side we see three
different versions of the story told
from kylo and luke's POV with the third
being a more accurate depiction of the
events that transpired known as the
Rashomon effect the definition states
the same event is given contradictory
interpretations by different individuals
involved the effect is named after Akira
Kurosawa's 1950 film Rashomon in which a
murder is described in four mutually
contradictory ways by its four witnesses
in the book the art of Star Wars the
last Jedi Jonson discussed his writing
process of the flashbacks which then
became part of the script during Lucas
Films 2015 holiday break which came
after Force awakens was in theaters on
the use of flashbacks Johnson states the
three flashbacks were elite edition one
of the last things that we went into the
script before we started shooting
translation flashbacks our cannon scene
is we've had two movies with two uses of
the flashback then episode 9 will surely
utilize the flashback again and in doing
so Luke can live again no messy retcon
no voodoo force magic bringing a dead
Jedi back to life this can happen so why
don't we end the skywalker saga with a
flashback to end all flashbacks an
adventure between master Skywalker and
his Padawan Ben solo I have your
attention I see if you immediately think
of the Clone Wars and some of the more
exciting and thrilling adventures with
obi-wan and Anakin well you're on the
same page as me the Star Wars movies
like to echo each other not only in
story but in its visual storytelling
Luke's hand is cut off and he loses his
lightsaber in the middle chapter of the
original trilogy Empire Strikes Back
Rey loses that same lightsaber in the
middle chapter of the sequel trilogy in
the last Jedi obi-wan watches his mentor
die at the hands of a Sith in Episode
one The Phantom Menace while Luke
watches his mentor die at the hands of a
Sith in Episode four a new hope these
are but a couple examples so why not
unite all three trilogies by echoing
what came before a flashback a scene and
a pivotal character moment in this
case it should be centered around kylo
Ren before his fall if we want to shed
more light on his dark turn let's see
the echoes of his own grandfather's fall
alongside Luke Skywalker kicking ass as
established in both sequel movies kylo
is tempted by the light and though he
was able to kill his father Han Solo he
couldn't quite pull the trigger when it
came to his mother Leia Snoke sensed it
but was also fooled by his trickery kylo
might have struggled to kill his parents
but he is still firmly entrenched in the
dark side as evidenced by his betrayal
of master Snoke
that's a classic Sith move and when Luke
Skywalker said see you around kid it's
implied that he will always be with his
former apprentice that the guilt and the
knowledge of his past actions will haunt
him forever so why is that let's cue the
flashback then somewhere in episode 9 we
flashback to a time where Luke and Ben
were together and on a mission for the
Jedi many years before the events of the
force awakens a time already seen in the
last Jedi
it should conjure to mind what came
before Shades of obi-wan Kenobi and
Anakin and even obi-wan in qui-gon
Master and apprentice on a mission to do
good for the galaxy like official Jedi
business
I understood that rivers that's where we
pick up with Luke and Ben in a flash
back on this flat fact this mission in
Episode nine Luke is alerted to the
presence of a dark side force let's say
in the outer rim or unknown regions on
this peacekeeping mission to stop the
dark side Luke and Ben come across the
existence of a powerful Sith enter
Supreme Leader Snoke you see how I'm
killing three birds with one stone now
we even get the origin of Snoke Luke and
Ben find Snoke battle a number of his
army the Praetorian guards which will
indeed show the full power of Master
Skywalker and given that the fans wanted
a pure example of leuf that they had in
their heads since returned the Jedi will
give them that Luke Master Skywalker and
his Padawan then defeat the army
learning of the formation of something
bigger something more menacing the first
step in a new order of villains
threatening the galaxy and let's say in
the last moment Snoke escapes but not
before seeing a glimpse of Ben's future
and as we close in on the darkside
energy inherent in snow kylo Ren snaps
out of a flashback the nightmare the
vision ends that's how you can maybe do
a flashback in episode 9 this story beat
is consumed
for Kyllo who was still struggling with
memories of his former master and he was
humiliated on crate and showing still
that he is grappling with the light and
is in fact haunted by Luke but that's
just me it's just speculation
nothing's out there yet there's no news
that this is gonna happen this is just
something I think fans would like and
something we've talked about on rule of
two I mean there's no knowing if that is
the angle JJ and ko will go in Episode
nine but it sure sounds fun
and it does show a way in which Luke
Skywalker could be alive in Episode nine
so what do you think could Luke be
utilized in a flashback scene will we
finally see the mighty awesomeness of
Master Skywalker alive and well at least
in a flashback in episode 9 so why do
you drop in your thoughts like and share
this video when you stay tuned for a
little bit more content coming from
Collider quick just like this
[Music]
you